on the first day of the trial you
issued a statement and part of the
statement said i still have love for
johnny
yes is that still true yes
after everything absolutely
absolutely
i love him
i loved him with all my heart amber
heard admitting she still loves
ex-husband johnny depp despite their
highly publicized legal battle you know
exactly why mr deb won't look back at
you don't you
i do while speaking with nbc news's
savannah guthrie amber says the 2018
washington post op-ed she wrote that led
to johnny's defamation case against her
was actually not about him the op-ed
wasn't about
my relationship with johnny but it
alluded to him it is unmistakable
you know what the op-ed was about was um
you know me loaning my voice to bigger
cultural conversation that we were
having at the time when you wrote this
op-ed it was the height of me too
legions of powerful men
being
canceled losing their jobs
did you want that to happen to johnny
depp of course not then savannah grills
amber about her divorce settlement a hot
topic during her cross-examination
sitting here today ms heard you still
haven't donated the seven million
dollars divorce settlement to charity
isn't that right
incorrect i pledged the entirety
of the settlement seven million to
charity and i
intend to fulfill those obligations and
say i donated
you know that everybody thinks that
you've donated it not that you've
pledged it so
for the jurors sitting there
do you think they felt like that was you
getting caught in a lie
i i don't know because so much of the
i feel like so
much of the trial was meant to
cast aspersions on who i am as a human
my credibility to call me a liar and in
every way you can and that was the trial
it was a credibility contest and that
was it by the end of the trial the jury
found that amber did defame johnny and
awarded him 15 million dollars in
punitive and compensatory damages
amber's biggest fear now that johnny
will sue her again i'm scared that
no matter what i do
no matter what i say or how i say it
um every step that i take
will present another opportunity
for
this sort of uh silencing
which is what i guess a defamation
lawsuit is meant to do it's meant to
to take your voice the actress also
feels that johnny made good on a certain
promise there's a text message where
johnny promises
total global humiliation for you
do you feel like that came true i'm not
a good victim i get it i'm not a
likeable victim i'm not a perfect victim
but
i
when i testified i asked the jury to
just see me
as human and hear
his own words
which is a promise to do this it feels
as though he has but now amber is ready
to fight back her lawyer revealed last
week that she's ready to appeal the
source tells 18 now amber's had time to
process the verdict she's feeling more
optimistic she's confident that her side
will come out eventually she has a plan
and strategy to make a comeback over the
next year but ultimately amber has no
hard feelings towards johnny despite
everything they've been through
i love him
i loved him with all my heart
and i tried the best i could to make a
deeply broken relationship work
and
i couldn't
i
have no bad feelings or ill will towards
him at all
[Music]